BRUNO AZIZA: Hi, everyone.
This is Bruno Aziza, and
today I am talking to Cody.
Now, Cody is going to talk to
us about real-time and anomaly
detection, one of
the design patterns
that we are delivering
to you this week.
If you don't remember
what design patterns are
and our conversation with
Robert last week on product
recommendation, these design
patterns are a starting point.
They're there to help you deploy
a solution for a given business
problem.
So anomaly detection
is a big one,
and Cody has a ton of
experience in that.
I've known him for a long time.
He was at Domo for seven
years, and now has been here
at Google for a year.
So, Cody, take us
through the genesis.
Why does real-time
matter to our customers?
CODY IRWIN: Real-time, I think,
matters to every company,
especially in this
digital transforming age.
Like, everything is changing.
I think 2020 has shown us very
clearly that companies that
can adapt quickly and understand
customers and understand
competitors and the
market in general
are those that ultimately win.
And we found that
real-time really
is the solution to help
them find answers quickly.
BRUNO AZIZA: So we
talked about real-time.
Now, how does this
real-time problem
relate to anomaly detection?
CODY IRWIN: So real-time, in and
of itself, is super exciting.
Like, everyone you've
met should be like, yeah,
of course I want real-time.
I want answers fast.
But the reality is, if we
just do real-time, if we just
take a real-time stream
and point it at a company,
at a problem, it could
make things worse
unless there's some more
intelligence built into it.
So we found that the sweet spot
tends to be combining real-time
data streams with
advanced analytics--
so AI, ML, in this
case, anomaly detection.
So helping organizations
find, in the moment,
those outliers, the unique
things that they should really
care about.
And those could be good or bad.
It could be like,
this is a risk.
Worry about this.
Or it could be like, hey,
something good is happening.
This is different.
Do more of this.
So we found that to be really
a sweet spot with real-time.
That's why [? protection ?]
is critical.
BRUNO AZIZA: We
have to tell people
that these design
patterns originate
from customers and partners
that tell us about their need.
And we go out and use the
best practices we have
and build this guidance, sample
code, architecture guidance,
so you can use those best
practices at your company.
So where did this story
on anomaly detection
start on your end?
CODY IRWIN: So we had a large
teleco provider approach us
and say, hey, I
have this problem.
And originally, it was actually
more of a processing problem.
They're like, we
have a lot of data.
We have this massive network.
We want to know what's
different in our traffic,
but we can't even
process the data.
So we started there.
And the awesome thing is, with
tools like Dataflow, BigQuery,
we were able to meet
their scaling needs.
So the requirements
were 250,000 events
per second that had
to be processed.
They kind of kicked
off this journey.
Like, we took that pattern,
we saw the problem.
And we've been kind of like
wrapping it up in a pattern
and saying, OK, does
anyone else have this need
for anomaly detection?
We've been amazed at how many
companies are like, yeah,
I have a problem.
I could use some help.
It is real-time in nature.
It really has turned into
kind of a rinse and repeat.
BRUNO AZIZA: That's excellent.
And that's the whole
point for why we're
building these design patterns.
So we want to invite you
to take advantage of them
right now by clicking on the
link down below, and of course
suggesting more design
patterns that you
might need for your rendition.
But before we go, I want
to talk about partners,
and how they added to
the ecosystem here.
One in particular,
I think, Confluent,
that you've been working with.
Tell us more about that.
CODY IRWIN: At Google Cloud
we love, love, love partners.
And in this case, Confluent
has been a pretty key partner
in helping us bridge the divide
between on-premise or other
clouds to GCP.
It's like, a lot of times
people are like, yeah,
I have this problem.
I'd love for Google
to help me solve it.
But the process for doing
the integration sometimes
isn't super-clear.
A lot of companies
are invested in Kafka.
Confluent is basically a
managed version of Kafka,
and so they made it
very, very easy for us
to create the integration
and capitalize
on this functionality.
I will say as well, when it
comes to the actual anomaly
detection, we found that a
number of other companies
have a lot of great
proprietary models
that get plugged in to this.
So our architecture is
actually somewhat transferable.
The pipeline is
pretty established.
Like, we know how to do
that really, really well.
We know how to integrate models.
I'm kind of more
generic models, but we
have partners that really
can augment that and bring
specialty into the actual need.
So for some organizations,
the patterns
are like the exact solution.
For others, the architecture
is the solution.
And a model fits really
well into an architecture.
BRUNO AZIZA: And so there's
value for customers,
there's value for
prospects listening to us,
there's value for partners.
There's value for everyone.
Again, if you are interested
in this design pattern,
make sure you click on
the link down below.
If you are interested in
others that we might not
have built yet, don't be
shy, and suggest which ones
you'd like us to build for you.
Cody, thank you so much
for the time today.
I hope people are going
to reach out to you.
We'll talk to you soon.
CODY IRWIN: Thanks, Bruno.